[Music]
our main story tonight concerns belarus
and i know you might be expecting me to
play that game where i tell you that's
not actually belarus it's somewhere else
but here's the thing
that game was supposed to encourage you
to learn some basic geography and
honestly i started to get the sense that
some of you just grew to enjoy being
humiliated by it which is why those
particular people will be happy to know
that that's not actually belarus that's
belarus happy now you're freaks
specifically we'd like to talk about
belarus's president and autocratic
leader alexander lukashenko who has had
quite a year in fact you might have
noticed stories about belarus popping up
with increasing regularity especially
since last august when they had a highly
contested election which made
international headlines
thousands of people unleashing their
fury in the capital city of minx and
elsewhere also around the country mr
lukashenko who has ruled for nearly
three decades has faced a wave of anger
over his handling of the coronavirus
pandemic and the economy as well despite
that official state approved exit polls
gave him an overwhelming majority of 80
percent
it's true they claimed lukashenko won
with 80
of the vote which was immediately fishy
for a couple of reasons one the massive
protest that followed and two the idea
that any man could still be popular
after nearly three decades in the public
eye i've only had this show for eight
years and even i can barely stand the
sight of me
and belarusians aren't just furious at
lukashenko for his handling of the
coronavirus although from the beginning
of the pandemic his mismanagement of it
was incredibly reckless at first he
called the virus a psychosis and said it
was treatable with vodka and saunas
and at a crowded hockey game he denied
its existence
i don't understand there are no viruses
here did you see any of them flying
around
oh yeah
yeah that makes sense doesn't it just
look around you you don't see any covet
viruses do you do you hear any ebola
smell any measles taste any aids in the
air no of course not that's how you know
they're not here what is here is your
fearless leader who's about to go and
score a hat-trick for the mint midlife
crisis
but lukashenka's terrible handling of
covid is just the beginning here he's
described himself as the last and only
dictator in europe which is in itself
just an amazing thing to say bragging
about being the last dictator he's like
bragging about being the last radio
shack or the last person to make a movie
with harvey weinstein it's not an
enviable title and sadly for some
belarusians he's the only leader they've
ever known
how old are you i am 22. you're 22. yeah
so your whole life you've lived under
one president how does that feel for you
well it feels like
yeah
yeah i bet it does
especially since the person who's been
in charge for that man's entire life is
a hard-boiled egg with a mustache who
calls himself a dictator and thinks
covid only exists if you can see it
zooming around in a tiny little jet
that process was from last september and
things have only escalated since then
you may remember a belarusian athlete
refusing to return home during the tokyo
olympics and back in may this happened
this morning belarus is facing growing
international protests and condemnation
after the country's president alexander
lukashenko sent a fighter jet to ground
a commercial plane flying between two
european capitals and with it 26 year
old dissident journalist roman protest
and his girlfriend one passenger says
roman pleaded don't do this they'll kill
me the ryanair crew replied we have no
choice
yeah a journalist who was critical of
the government briefly passed through
belarusian airspace on a commercial
flight so lukashenko personally ordered
a fighter jet to intercept it and force
it to land now belarusian authorities
originally claimed that they did that
because of an emailed bomb threat from
hamas but records show that email was
sent 24 minutes after they informed the
pilot about the bomb threat not to
mention it was sent from ahmed yolanov
1988 at protonmail.com
with the subject line allahu akbar which
is just
impossibly lazy it's just
one step above emailing from
badguy6969 yahoo.com with a subject line
terrorist stuff parentheses like 911.
so given how much things seem to be
spiraling in belarus we thought tonight
it'll be worth giving you some context
for what is happening over there and
taking a look at exactly who alexander
lukashenko is and let's start with the
fact that he is the greatest president
in the history of belarus specifically
because he's the only president in the
history of belarus lukashenko won the
country's first free and fair election
in 1994 three years after the fall of
the soviet union when he a former
manager of a state-owned farm vowed to
raise taxes on the rich and defeat
corruption it sounded great and he was
genuinely popular at the time just
listen to a former aids turned critic
recall how people reacted to lukashenko
at his rallies
3 000 people who were listening to him
instead of leaving the stadium move
towards him like an avalanche
i remember as if it happened yesterday
they were reaching out to him like
believers to a relic praying for god's
grace
women were lifting up their children for
lukashenko to touch them others were
reaching out with books newspapers or
even banknotes just to get his autograph
well lukashenko was no michael jackson
but this is what really happened well
well hold on there because
was he no michael jackson think about it
lukashenko was immensely popular in the
90s die hard fans packed stadiums to see
him and eventually torpedoed his
reputation because it turns out he was
an absolute monster to be honest i think
lukashenko fully earned that comparison
and he still very much plays up his
humble farm background through photo ops
like this one where he's harvesting
potatoes while dressed like chef
boyardee at an orgy
he once gave four bags of potatoes and
the tub of lard to vladimir putin as a
christmas gift and when steven seagal
visited belarus lukashenko also gifted
him produce with the washington post
poetically writing at the time there was
no hesitation on steve seagal's face as
he took a raw freshly peeled carrots
from the hands of the belarusian
president alexander lukashenko and bit
into it with a satisfying chomp
which is just
an elegant tapestry of words you don't
even need a video to imagine what it was
like to see steven seagal using his
mouth bones to break off the tip of that
rabbit hot dog but
you know what we're going to show it to
you anyway
[Applause]
magnificent look no disrespect no
disrespect to cigar classics like under
siege hard to kill above the law and
probably something called hunting the
fire or whatever
but that is the greatest film steven
seagal has ever made
but for all lukashenko's common man
posturing his promises to combat
corruption quickly fell apart just five
months into his presidency a deputy
compiled an investigation into
corruption in parliament which was said
to have contained charges against
various high-ranking officials but the
government banned all press coverage of
the report to the point where local
newspapers that have planned to publish
the results of it instead ended up
publishing blank pages like these and
that was just the beginning of a
decades-long assault on the press
shortly afterward lukashenko replaced
the editors in chief of four leading
newspapers and took the national radio
and television under strict control
creating an environment so hostile to
independent journalism belarus is now
considered the most dangerous country in
europe for members of the media with
members constantly subjected to violence
arbitrary detentions interrogations
raids and more and the control
lukashenka exerts over even small petty
details is incredible
is it true that you cannot film the back
of lukashenka's head
yes
it's true it's because he's has a bold
patch or yeah it's a kind of very weird
uh haircut so it's growing from one side
wait a minute
wait a minute hold on there
you're telling me this guy is bald this
guy
this guy
this man right here you're telling me
that this guy
is bald bald you say
you know what i think you might actually
be right he looks like he kind of grew
his left sideburn into a rat tail and
then chillaxed it onto his bare scalp
the answer to the question is lukashenko
bald at this point it's a resounding oh
i wish
but lukashenka's bizarre behavior goes
well beyond censoring the media and
force-feeding stephen cigar or
vegetables
over the years he's made statements like
better to be a dictator than gay and not
everything connected in germany with the
well-known adolf hitler was bad really
taking the phrase playing devil's
advocate a bit too literally and if
you're thinking okay but who didn't
accidentally praise hitler in the 90s
first
why are you thinking that
and second just this summer he said the
entire world grovels to the jews which
is obviously awful lukashenko treats
anti-semitism the way fashion treats
low-rise bell-bottoms he keeps bringing
it back even when it was never
acceptable at any point in history
overall it seems lukashenko operates
from the standard authoritarian playbook
and he's repeatedly worked to codify his
power using a controversial referendum
in 1996 to extend his first term and
dramatically increase his powers and
weaken those of the legislature and then
using a second referendum to completely
remove term limits in 2004 at this point
outside observer groups have reported
that none of his last five election
victories have been legitimate and
throughout his time as president
lukashenk has clamped down hard on the
slightest signs of descent in 2012 two
men staged toy protests with stuffed
animals holding auntie lukashenko
slogans objectively the cutest display
of civil disobedience that i've ever
seen but
that wound up getting both of those men
sentenced to 10 days in jail a sentence
that in itself actually inspired a
follow-up protest
in july hundreds of teddy bears rained
down on belarus they wore parachutes and
carried pro-democracy messages the man
behind the prank is a marketing
executive with a swedish firm he took
off from lithuania in this tiny plane
for 90 minutes he let the fur fly
perfect i love it
10 out of 10 there
we should be dropping parachuting teddy
bears from the sky here all the time not
even as an active protest it should just
be a thing that we do oh it's 1 p.m
everyone it's daily parachuting teddy
bear time why did we even invent planes
if we're not going to use them to drop
teddy bears out of the sky and instantly
improve everybody's day i don't
understand the society we've built for
ourselves we are idiots
now look
unsurprisingly
lukashenko tried to cover that incident
up which proved to be impossible due to
you know the existence of the internet
so instead he tried to save face by
firing two generals the head of the
border service and the head of the air
force but the thing is
even though protests like those can be
whimsical what happens to distance in
belarus is absolutely horrific
opposition figures have disappeared over
the years and some are suspected to have
been murdered by the state and there
have been numerous allegations of
political detainees being tortured as
this bbc journalist once tried to
demonstrate in what i will say
is a pretty bold manner
the opposition in belarus say they were
tortured by being forced to strip naked
in freezing conditions
so we go to a cold store in north london
where the temperature
is minus 24 celsius
so the guards forced the prisoners to
strip naked
and stand
in this position spread eagles
and -20 there was snow outside
in the jargon of torture this is a
stress position
[Applause]
quick question and it actually has a
nothing to do with the prisoner torture
why did you do that
you could have just told us the
prisoners were forced to stand in the
cold naked we'd have believed you
and we'd been able to imagine what that
looks like we really didn't need to see
you standing there cakes out
to get your very basic point
[Applause]
and the thing is that brutality has only
escalated recently lukashenka has
increased the number of arrests of human
rights activists and journalists and
police have raided their offices and
homes just this week an opposition
leader was sentenced by the state to 11
years in prison and even when dissidents
managed to escape belarus they may not
be safe a few weeks ago an activist
who'd fled to ukraine went out for a run
and was found hanged in a park and while
that has not yet been officially
confirmed as a murder
come on
i'm not sure which species of trees are
native to ukraine but i don't think any
of them naturally have belarusian
dissidents hanging from them the point
here is for nearly three decades now
belarus has experienced a brutal cycle
of oppression in which lukashenko wins
elections that are neither free nor fair
locks up his political opponents people
take to the streets in protest and he
violently cracks down it is no wonder
the belarusian people seem to have had
enough a leaked poll showed that only
about a third of the population trusts
lukashenko which is impressively low
considering remember he controls the
national media and even there his grip
seems to be slipping though last year
presenters on a state tv morning show
walked off and resigned leaving viewers
watching this
[Music]
wow that is that is both a brave act of
protest by belarusian broadcasters and
also
everyone's dream panel on the view and
and you do you do get the sense
lukashenko may be starting to feel some
pressure here because when marches
likened him to a cockroach and online
polls showed him having only three
percent support from his people instead
of simply ignoring that this is how he
responded
to the editor do you really believe that
the serving president has just three
percent support
stop harassing and insulting us calling
me a mustache cockroach etc i am still
the president of this country in no
country in the world are you allowed to
insult people
uh
yes you are
yeah yeah you definitely are here i'll
prove it to you
your suit's too big you're suck at
hockey and whatever it is you do with
your hair isn't working see
not
not in jail
i'm not in jail so look things are
clearly bleak in belarus and svetlana
ticonofsky the woman widely believed to
be the real winner of last year's
election and who by the way only ran
after her husband lukashenka's initial
opponent was imprisoned has fled the
country but she is still leading the
country's pro-democracy movement from
exile she's asked world leaders to
demand the release of what is thought to
be over 650 political prisoners and i
will say the eu the u.s the uk and
canada have imposed sanctions on belarus
targeting everything from close
associates of lukashenko to the
belarusian economy and the boyd
administration has just recently imposed
more but the truth is
sanctions can only do so much here and
lukashenka does not seem keen to end his
reign in fact many think that he's
groomed his youngest son collier to take
his place because since he was young
lukashenka has been dragging him along
everywhere he goes on state business
here he is here he is again here he's
again he's in all of these photos i
don't know exactly when european bring
your kid to work day is but it can't be
always
so at this point it looks like the only
thing that will really improve things in
belarus is if the people there somehow
managed to reform their constitution and
ensure that free and fair elections are
finally held and as we have seen tonight
fighting for those changes is going to
be incredibly risky but there may be one
extremely small way that we can actually
help here or if not help at least annoy
the out of lukashenko because if
there is one thing that we know he hates
other than gay people jews his old bald
head and anyone who disagrees with him
it is teddy bears and frankly
why wouldn't he i mean look at them
there everything that he's not cute
lovable and covered in thick natural
hair all the way around so
we actually decided to make our own
special teddy bear in his honor as you
can see he's uh wearing a shirt with
farmer lukashenka's favorite vegetables
in a totally random configuration if you
think they look like something else what
does that say about you and
and instead of dropping them from a
plane over belarus we're actually
offering them to you at this website
belarusbearforce.com for the price of
19.99 we've partnered with global giving
to give a hundred percent of sales to
organizations fighting for the freedom
of the press and human rights for the
people of belarus so please
buy one of these bears and not just for
the people of belarus but for my sake
too we bought 10 000 of these things
and if we don't get rid of all of them
i'm in real go to
belarusbearforce.com
buy one for yourself your parents your
least politically informed co-worker or
your friend's new baby who you have no
idea what to get because it's not like
you've ever hung out with it before so
be sure to order your teddy bear today
and support the people of belarus i
promise you they are flight ready
that is our show
thank you so much for watching it's
great to be back good night
you